coincé attendent après un truc qu qui va
falloir que justice prend le large pour
aller me fleurier ionienne gratifiant
ladder elle consomme en moyenne pour 275
$ de crack par jour son proxénète la
tient par son point faible
lipow en ce moment moi j'ai surgi désolé
pour l'extrait cru mais ça fait partie
aussi de cette réalité de la
prostitution
on en parle beaucoup depuis plusieurs
semaines vous savez un projet de loi
important fédéral on en reparlera mais
l'an dernier ce qui était à l'antenne au
mois de juillet vous avez vu donc ce
reportage une jeune toxicomane qui
devait se prostituer pour finalement
acheté un sa drogue et bien un an plus
tard ma collègue marié ève tremblay l'a
retrouvé et vous serez surpris du chemin
qu'elle a parcouru en garde le reportage
et ensuite on parle à stéphanie à sa
mère
stéphanie nous a donné rendez vous sous
son arbre à laval le seul endroit où
elle trouvait la quiétude
alors qu'il vivait son enfer suite aux
premiers reportages après l'avoir vu
disons que j'ai réalisé beaucoup ce que
je vivais puis j'ai décidé de m'en
sortir je vous renvoie 31 et aux pieds
je ne me voyais pas arriver à 50 ans
encore à faire les mêmes choses que je
faisais puis à consommer à tous les
jours puis en cour suprême magané je me
suis donné une chance
stéphanie a abandonné la prostitution et
les sobre depuis un an
pourtant à l'époque elle consommait pour
300 dollars de crack par jour elle a
décidé de prendre sa vie en main avec
beaucoup de patience beaucoup courage le
fait de de prendre distance tout le
monde avec qui je me tenais ça l'a aidé
beaucoup et puis je pense que le spalle
de ma mère et d énormément
le fait de voir de la fierté dans ses
yeux de voeu de voir que sa fille
voulait s'en sortir ça m'a aidé beaucoup
elle avait déjà tenté l'expérience des
thérapies mais après plusieurs
tentatives sans succès
c'est finalement sa volonté qui a été
plus forte que tout quintana vraiment à
ces camps clocheton fond c'est vraiment
le vouloir parce que j'ai pas eu besoin
d'être enfermés ou d'être coupé de toute
réalité si je les fait à la dure c'est
parce que si j'aurais vraiment voulu
j'aurais pu retourner consommer
n'importe quelle passe pas mauvais
dupont en soi mais moi je surgi à ma
consommation
j'ai plein mondial c'est ma drogue
seydou de voix la déchéance sociale voit
la mort de proches c'est jouer avec la
main sur ces photos où l'on voit
stéphanie plus jeunes rien ne laissait
deviner ce qu'elle allait devenir sa
mère nathalie a trouvé les 15 dernières
années difficiles je regardais une
nouvelle l'avait déjà un moment donné
l'une benthum danic avait été retrouvée
morte dans une ruelle sur un mac l'eau
jg j'ai viré la villa navarre et j'étais
dans les trois cas où j'ai fait de
pignan ontario et jusqu à table il n'a
pas une pipe roche sur pie-ix 6 mais
aussi qu'on est rendu de l'eau on est
loin l'eau on est loin là on est en beau
loup dans l'enfer c'est l'enfer
celui qui n'est pas l'italie d'andy reid
a des chalets enneigés rien on ne renie
pas le profil pour essayer de la santé
de blues qui
arrivé le temps de se remettre en selle
stéphanie touche de l'aide sociale elle
participe à des rencontres de
cocaïnomanes anonymes et fait du
bénévolat
prochaine étape trouver du travail si je
suis capable d'aller travailler à
n'importe quelle température qui pouvait
avoir pu jeter tout à ses mains ou même
des romains place puis je pense va être
capable d'être ponctuel pour aller au
travail puis de de fonctionner
normalement
quoi qu'il en soit pour l'instant la vie
de stéphanie a changé aujourd'hui je
peux dire est que je te rejoins oui je
la prends avec le bonheur
stéphane et nathalie ces grades sont
avec nous bonsoir madame stéphanie
d'abord qu'est-ce qui a été le plus dur
pour te sortir de tout ça on a entendu
ta mère dans le reportage extraordinaire
vous vous vous étiez en train de penser
que c'était la fin puis qu'est-ce qui a
été le déclic
ma relation avec mon copain ça a été un
gros déclic
et puis après avoir vu le reportage ça
me fait quelque chose puis je me suis
dit non je veux pas continuer comme ça
il est temps que je m'en sorte fakir
j'ai décidé faire l'effort et vous êtes
jeu le souligneront le dit dans le
reportage
mais vous êtes resté combien de temps à
vous prostituées et donc à vous droguer
c'est un grand moment de présence
15 15 est ce qu'il ya eu des tentatives
pendant les quinze ans on vous entend
dire oh j'y suis de la sortir où j'étais
prêt
non il ya eu il ya plus eu plusieurs
projets essayé puis a finalement gens
retournaient tout le temps vers ça je
n'étais pas prêt je n'ai juste pas
prêtre maintenant ça va faire un an et
puis je suis fier de mon ami je
comprends je vous le dit dans le
reportage
de voir votre fille et quand vous l'avez
retrouvé image est très forte nu pieds
sur la rue pinel quoi les diorios on
peut pas les plus beaux gosses n'ont
absolument pas une descente aux enfers
très rapide c'est des drogues traits
d'une cd vix ont dû céder ville détruite
détruite parce qu'ils ont plus de points
en plus de repas en ville sont mangés
corps humain par la drogue
et vous ce qu'il faut expliquer c'est
que vous n'étiez pas forcé ou
prostituées c'était votre consommation
de drogue qui vous force et avoue
prostituées oui oui oui parce que j'ai
jamais eu d'emploi légal et puis c'était
leur glace lindgren khrouchtchev
acquiert pour survenir asos j'ai été
vers le chemin facilité j'aimais mieux
faire ça que d'aller voler ou et pour
moi c'était plus simple yo je le disais
en représentation du reportage et un
débat au canada sur la prostitution et
d'ailleurs je très content qu'on montre
ça parce que des fois il ya des
tentatives de romantiser un peu la
prostitution
vous vous l'avais dit en termes très
crus c'est épouvantable ce que vous avez
dû faire aussi
oui oui oui c'est pas un bon dans lequel
vous vous plaisir du tout non non c'est
sûr c'est quand tu donnes la seule chose
qui t'appartient réellement envie elle
appela du monde que tu connais pas c'est
pas très agréable mais qu'est ce que
vous pensez donc de ce projet de loi du
gouvernement conservateur à ottawa de
criminaliser les clients jeu va vous
entendre l'étude - personnellement je
suis pas d'accord avec ça parce que pour
ces faits là les bons clients ils iront
pu fait les seuls clients qui vont leur
reste et c'est le texte commun c'est les
mauvais payeurs c'est ce ne sera pas
mieux pour eux sont donc ça va empirer
audit le sort des prostituées de rue
rouge a passé vous absolument ça va
empirer les choses pour les filles de
rue qui savoure aggraver des situations
familiales parce qu'il faut penser aussi
aux hommes qui ont des familles
si c'est un métier qui a toujours été et
cela depuis que mère et monde donc c'est
pas quelque chose qu'on peut retirer
comme ça ça va quand même qu'il est
criminaliserait sais que ça va partir
dans les fonds encore plus cacher et
c'est pas parce que vous approuvez ce
métier là parce qu'on l'a vu tous les
efforts que vous avez fait déployer pour
aller sortir votre fille de ses griffes
là vous saviez que c'était un enfer oui
parce qu'il faut comprendre que la
drogue amène à la position et la
position amène à la dronne donc pour se
pourrait que stéphanie soit capable de
se droguer a fait des clients à faisait
des clients et pour faire les clients il
fallait qu'elle se drogue à quel moment
vous avez pris le mauvais tournant à
quel âge à qui il m'a manqué ce qui est
arrivé je palin à toutes vos questions
familiales mais quel moment ça des
rapides
à moi ça dérape lit quand j'avais 16 ans
quand je t'ai revers montréal ouais
c'était la première fois que j'arrivais
dans une grande ville je rencontrais
pleinement
ok c'est bon c'était comme le portique
commencé à 16 ans oui ok mais de là le
parti qui commence à se retrouver dans
la rue se prostituer il ya une marge
qu'est-ce qui a fait que c'est allé si
loin ben moi je suis à 100 des cas et
puis je me suis juge et partie infime de
mon centre d'accueil et puis pour
subvenir à mes besoins ben j'ai
rencontré des gens qui m'ont dit bah
écoute
bref un saut puis on va t berger puis me
donnait de la drogue
et puis donc au début il y avait des
pubs il y avait des points il faisait
travailler oui oui donc il y avait de
l'exploitation de ce coût moyen
si l'exploitation côté sentiments et
motif qu'ils avaient
oui en terme pbl des films c'est
toujours le même temps qui revient dans
ce que stéphanie natale mascotte
d'abord on a beaucoup ce qui nous a
intéressé dans votre reportage puis dans
votre histoire c'est que après
un an le progrès il est remarquable les
gens qui ont vu le reportage le dit on
vous voit pas très bien mon comprendre
et d'accepter une tpo la même personne
j'ai tjrs et j'étais au plus bas
effectivement bravo bonne chance
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire un
quelques secondes et vous des projets
mais j'aimerais ça ouvrir un salon de
toilettage canin que j'adore les animaux
fait que celle ci dans mes projets de
vie allait prendre des cours entre les
tâches cannes un billet mais crée un
multi vous avez dit dans le reportage
j'ai été capable de travailler la pluie
mauvais temps tout ça serait plus facile
la vie des chiens que ce que vous
faisiez oui oui parce qu'on est jeu pour
faire de la joute book madame la télé
merci d'être venu nous voir également
elle m'a fait plaisir très gentil mais à
voir la mnef